يواجهه سبعه من جنائيه لاحتفاضه بوثائق
سريه ومكارث يتوعد اداره باردا بالمحاسبه
يستعد لتقديم مساعدات عسكريه جديده لكياف
يتحدث عن تحقيق نتائج شرق اوكرانيا
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه تعلن ممثل الامم
المتحده الخاص
شخصا غير مرغوب فيه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره اخباريه من العربيه قال رئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انه طلب منه
المسؤول امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي
يوم الثلاثاء المقبل اضاف ان اتهاما وجه
اليه في اطار التحقيق حول وثائق البيت
الابيض واصفا ذلك بيوم اسود في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مصدر مطلع كشف
ان هيئه محلفين اتحاديه كبرى وجهت سبع تهم
جنائيه للرئيس الامريكي السابق لاحتفاضه
بوثائق حكوميه سريه
وعرقله سير العداله
لديك رئيس حصل على اصوات اكثر من اي رئيس
في التاريخ حتى الان وهم يلاحقونني لاننا
نتقدم في استطلاعات الراي كثيرا ضد بايدن
وضد الجمهوريين نحن متقدمين ضد بايدن
كثيرا بكمية هائله وصعدنا الى مستوى حيث
اكتشفوا ان الطريقه الوحيده التي
سيوقفوننا بها هي بشن الحرب هذه حرب
باستخدام القانون لا يمكننا السماح بحدوث
ذلك بلدنا ذاهب الى الجحيم وهم يتابعون
دونالد ترامب وقاموا باستخدام وزاره العدل
ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي كسلاح لا
يمكننا ان ندع هذا يستمر لانه يمزق بلادنا
الى اشلاء لدينا مشاكل كبيره ولا ينبغي ان
تكون هذه واحده منها
رئيس مجلس نواب الامريكي كذا
الاتهام للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب وقال
انه فعلا يوم اسود في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده مكارتي اكد ان نواب الجمهوريين
سيحاسبون الاداره الحاليه على الاستغلال
المشين للسلطه معتبرا انه من غير المعقول
ان يتهم رئيسنا المرشح الرئيسي المنفس له
كما اعلن مكارتي انه وكل امريكي يؤمن
بسياده القانون يقف الى جانب ترامب
معنى من واشنطن البحث في الشؤون الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس سيد ايهاب
اهلا بك هل كان متوقعا توجيه هذه التهام
الجنائيه لدونالد ترامب في هذا التوقيت
نعم اهلا بحضرتك استاذه سهام واهلا بكل
المشاهدين لا اعتقد انه كان امرا متوقعا
بل بالعكس ياتي في وقت يعني غريب نوعا ما
لم تكن هناك اي سوابق تدل على هذا الامر
لكن لنقل ان التوجيه التهم لم يتم بالشكل
الرسمي بعد من المنتظر ان يمثل الرئيس
السابق دونالدو امام المحكمه في يوم
الثلاثاء القادم يعني بعد الظهر ومن ثم
سنعرف عندها ما هي نوعيه التهم التي ستوجه
اليه وان كانت تدور في اطار يعني مخالفه
القوانين المتعلقه باخراج الوثائق من
البيت الابيض خاصه انه اكتشف لديه عدد
طبعا كبير من الوثائق في منتجع ماراليجو
في
فلوريدا وبالتالي ربما سيكون هناك تهم
حقيقيه هذه المره لان الرجل منذ يعني عام
2016 وحتى اليوم الكثير من محاولات
الاتهام والادانه ولكن كلها هدف دائما
توضع مهاجمه ترامب ومعه الجمهوريين
للعداله باساءه استخدام السلطه
وباستخدامها سياسيا كسلاح
والله يعني السير الاحداث دائما
ياتينا بهذا المشهد
لا توجد اي
ادله اتهام حقيقيه من الممكن ان يتم اتهام
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامبيا ودائما يكون
هناك محاولات للاطاحه به ولذلك هو دائما
يتحدث هو والجمهوريون طبعا عن ان هناك
محاولات اطاحه سياسيه
بالرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب من المشهد
السياسي لمحاوله منعه من خوض السباق
الرئاسي القادم كل المحاولات الماضيه طبعا
الرئيس دونالد ترامب والجمهوريون يعتبرون
انها محاولات من قبل الديمقراطيه مباشره
وهذا ايضا امر مثير للانتباه لان هذا يعني
ان هناك اذا ما ثبت بالفعل سيعني ان هناك
محاولات للتسيس اجهزه انفاذ القانون
والعداله الامريكيه لمصاحات الديمقراطيه
لا نستطيع ان نتهمهم بهذا الاتهام الخطير
لكن هو الاتهام الذي يواجهه دائما
دونالد ترامب والجمهوريون خاصه قيادات
الحزب الجمهوري المتعاطفه مع رئيس دونالد
ترامب للديمقراطيين لكن لا توجد عليه ايه
ادله حتى اللحظه طيب الى لماذا تشكل هذه
التهم الجنائيه الجديده انتكاسا قانونيه
اخرى لترام في الوقت الذي يسعى فيه لتولي
الرئاسه من جديد العام المقبل
يعني انا لا اعتقد انها سترتقي لتهم
جنائيه اعتقد انها ستكون مخالفات قانونيه
لقوانين متعلقه
بالبيت الابيض من الممكن ان يستطيع المدعي
العام الخاص الذي عين من قبل وزاره العدل
لتحقيق في هذه يعني تسريب هذه الوثائق او
يعني اخراج هذه الوثائق من البيت الابيض
من الممكن ان يستطيع ان يحولها الى جنايه
بالفعل ولكن لا اعتقد انها ستؤثر على رئيس
رونالد ترامب طبقا للدستور الامريكي هو ما
زال يستطيع ان يترشح وان
يفوز بالانتخابات حتى وان يمارس مهام
منصبه من السجن اذا وصلت الامور لهذه
المرحله
ترامب حتى لا يترشح هو يفترض ان تتم
ادانته في امور
متعلقه
يعني الاضرار بمصالح الامن القومي
الامريكي العليا وهذا امر مستبعد في هذه
الحاله التي نحن بها شكرا جزيلا لك من
واشنطن الباحثه الشؤون الامريكيه
والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس شكرا جزيلا
ينتظر ان تعلن الولايات المتحده عن حزمه
مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا تقدر
قيمتها باكثر من مليارين دولار وفقا ما
ذكرته وكاله بلومبر نقلا عن مسؤولين
بالاداره الامريكيه جاف التقرير ان حزمه
المساعدات الجديده تتعلق اساسا بوسائل
الدفاع الجوي وستساعد اوكرانيا على التزود
بمنصه الصواريخ هوك ونوعين من صواريخ
باتريوتا المتطوره للدفاع الجوي
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن دعا خلال لقائه
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني لوجوب الاستمرار
في دعم اوكرانيا وذلك رغم معارضه بعض
الاصوات في الكونجرس الامريكي
اعتقد انه سيكون لدينا تمويل لازم لدعم
اوكرانيا مهما تطلب الامر واعتقد اننا
ذاهبون لذلك وان هذا الدعم سيكون حقيقيا
على الرغم من انك تسمع بعض الاصوات اليوم
في الكونجرس حول ما اذا كان ينبغي علينا
الاستمرار في دعم اوكرانيا ام لا والى متى
يجب ان ندعمهم في حقيقه الامر اطلب من
الناس تصور ما يمكن ان يحدث لو لم نكن
ندعم اوكرانيا هل تعتقد ان روسيا ستتوقف
في كييف هل تعتقد ان كل هذا سيحدث لا
اعتقد ذلك واعتقد ان الغالبيه العظمى من
زملاء حتى النقاد يعتقدون ان الامر لن
يكون كذلك ايضا هناك الكثير لنقوله عن
اوكرانيا لكنني امل ان يجيب هذا على سؤالك
وسط تقرير متضاربه بشان انطلاق الهجوم
الاوكراني الموضع تحدث الرئيس الاوكراني
عن تحقيق النتائج بعد معارك عنيفه شرق
اوكرانيا وذلك دون تقديم تف
نحن على تواصل دائم مع جيشنا قاده مجموعه
القوات خورتيدسيا وتافريا مع جميع
المشاركين في المناطق حيث القتال اكثر
ضراوه تواجه منطقه الدنيا كما عادك صعبه
للغايه لكن هناك نتيجه وانا ممتن لكل من
يعمل على تحقيق هذه النتيجه
وكان اربعه مسؤولين اوكرانيين كشفوا
لصحيفه الواشنطن الامريكيه على الهجوم
المضاده الذي طال انتظاره قد بدا
الاستعاده سياده دوله اوكرانيا ووفق
المسؤولين الاربعه الذين يعملون في القوات
المسلحه فان القوات الاوكرانيه كثفت
هجماتها على طول خط المواجهه في جنوب شرق
البلاد وذلك بهدف تحرير مدينتي ميلتروبول
وانهدار التي سيطرت عليهما روسيا ضمن
عملياتها العسكريه الخاصه هناك
من جهاته قلقائد مجموعه العسكريه الروسيه
ان المعارك على الجبهه تؤكد ان اوكرانيا
بدات هجومها المضاد اوضح في تصريحات صحفيه
للقوات الاوكرانيه تكثف هجومها على جبهات
القتال كما تم التخطيط له وعلى بقائد
فاجنر عن اماله في ان تتمكن القوات
الروسيه من التعامل مع هذا الهجوم وصده
مؤكده ثقته في الجيش الروسي
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد او الصامت كما
بات يعرف يبدو انه قد بدا بالفعل وفق ما
نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
عسكريين اوكرانيين وعلى ما يبدو ان ملامح
الهجوم المضاد بدات تتكشف حيث اشار
المسؤولون الى ان الهجمات كثفت في مناطق
بجنوب شرقي البلاد
وبحسب الصحيفه فان الهدف الرئيسي هو قطع
طريق البري الرئيسي بين شبه جزيره القرم
وجنوب روسيا اهم طرق الامدادات الروسيه
والجبهه الاكثر ترجيحا ستكون في زبروجيا
وهي الجبهه التي شهدت الساعات الماضيه
هجوما للقوات الاوكرانيه على القوات
الروسيه وبحسب وزير الدفاع الروسي فان
الهجوم نفذه اللواء سبعه واربعون
ميكانيكيين اوكراني وهو كلمه السر في
الهجوم المضاد المنتظر
اللواء يبلغ تعداده 1500 جندي و150 مدرعه
تلقى تدريبات لاشهر في قاعده للنيتو
بالمانيا
اكتسب خبره ومهارات في تكتيكات النيتو
الحربيه الاكثر تقدما وهو مسلح باسلحه
ومعدات وتقنيات غربيه
قياده اللواء تدربت على اجهزه كمبيوتر
تحاكي المواقف التي قد يواجهونها في
المعارك الواقعيه ودرسوا نتائج المحاكاه
وبحسب واشنطن بوست فان اللواء سبعه
واربعين نقل الى موقع سري اقرب الى خط
الجبهه بعد تسليح وتدريب للقتال مثل
الجيوش الغربيه لكن بمفردهم ذاك اختبار
للاستراتيجيه التي تقودها الولايات
المتحده تقول موسكو على لسان وزير الدفاع
ان هذه القوه المدربه خصيصا لتحقيق اختراق
فشلت بمهمتها والحقت بها خسائر كبيره
هذا ولا تزال مضاعفات ازمات تدمير سد نوفا
كخوفوكا في مقاطعه خرسون تلقي بظلالها على
احوال المواطنين القاطنين في تلك المناطق
حيث غمرت المياه بيوتهم واتلفت حاجياتهم
ما تسبب في تشرد الالاف مفرد العربيه رصد
الوضع في كخوفكا والتقى بعض المتضررين
هناك
منعنا من التصوير في هذه المنطقه وقال لنا
الجنود بان الدفاع الروسيه اصدرت بيانا
بمنع التصوير في كل مناطق نوبيكا خوفكا
هذه هي
المياه التي فاضت من سد نوفا وغمرت
المناطق السكنيه وكذلك مناطق اخرى
ندخل هذه المناطق بحذر حيث وصل منسوب
المياه كما نرى في بيت هذه العائله الى
مستوى مرتفع جدا هذه المنطقه بالفعل
غمرتها المياه بالكامل ونحن ننقل الصوره
لقناه العربيه والحدث من مدينه نوفيخوفكا
حيث المياه التي جرفت كل ما صادفته في
طريقها بعد قصف محطه او سد نوفيكا خوفكا
الذي فاضت فيه المياه وارتفع منسوبها الى
هذه الدرجه
بالكاد حفظنا على الوثائق والاموال
والامتعه وعدنا اليوم لجمع ما نحتاج اليه
بدات المياه تتدفق بشكل مريع وكان صعبا
للغايه فعل اي شيء اسرعنا للحفاظ على ما
نحتاجه بعيدا عن المياه ونقلنا بعد
نسمع اصوات اطلاق الرصاص من حولنا وسقوط
القذائف والصواريخ طبعا
ايضا الكهرباء مقطوعه داخل المنزل
وفي المنطقه بشكل عام هو هذه اثار الطوفان
الذي وصل الى اطراف المدينه البعيده عن
السد بعد منتصف ليله امس توقفت المياه بعد
التيار القوي ومن ثم بدات بالانجراف وبدا
منسوب ارتفاعها بالتراجع قليلا والان
المياه ثابته عند هذا المستوى نحن هنا
نعيش منذ زمن طويل ونريد السلامه ان يعم
المنطقه
يحذرنا رجال الامن من انتشار الالغام التي
جرفتها السيول والفيضانات في جميع انحاء
هذه المنطقه حيث يمكن ان يتفجر لغم في اي
مكان وفي اي لحظه لقناتي العربيه والحدث
رائد الاغبر نفك خوفكا
قدم في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي من الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري قانون يسمحوا لوزاره
العدل بنقل اصول روسيه مصادره الى
اوكرانيا اوضح سيناتور الديمقراطي عن
فرجينيا الغربيه انه يمكن لوزاره العدل
الامريكيه بعد موافقه مجلس الشيوخ على
مشروع القانون نقل الاصول التي تمت
مصادرتها الى اوكرانيا لخدمه جهود الدفاع
واعاده الاعمار
اخطرت الحكومه السودانيه الامينه العام
الامم المتحده انها تعتبر فولكر بيرستا
غير مرغوب فيه واوضحت وزاره الخارجيه
افاده بان حكومه جمهوريه السودان قد اخطرت
الامين العام للامم المتحده رسميا امس
باعلان فولكربرت ممثل الامين العام للامم
المتحده ورئيس بعثه شخصا غير مرغوب فيه
شاهد محيط مجمع صناعات العسكريه في جنوب
الخرطوم اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع وذلك بعد اعلان
الاخيره سيطرتها عليه قال شهود عيان انهم
سمعوا اصوات اطلاق نار واشتباكات كما
شاهدوا حريقا في المنطقه المحيطه بمجمع
اليرموك
اشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا تطلقان شراكه
اقتصاديه جديده لمواجهه طموحات الصين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد احتفل الدول ومجلس
التعاون الخليجي والعراق في مدينه الخبر
بالسعوديه باعلان بدء مشروع الربط
الكهربائي الخارجي بين دول مجلس التعاون
والعراق يذكر ان تشغيل المشروع سيكون مع
نهايه العام المقبل وسيزود المشروع جنوب
العراق بالطاقه الكهربائيه حيث سيكون
باكوره التعاون والتبادل التجاري بين دول
مجلس التعاون والعراق بحسب هيئه الربط
الكهربائي الخليجي يتكون المشروع من ثلاث
مراحل حيث تبدا المرحله الاولى بتجهيز
محافظه البصره بجنوب العراق بجهد خمسمئه
يمكن رفعها بحسب الحاجه فيما بعد الى 1000
ميجا وات في مراحل متقدمه
وخلال الحفله كد وزير الطاقه السعودي عبد
العزيز بن سلمان ان الربطه الكهربائي بين
دول الخليج والعراق يحقق فوائد اقتصاديه
ملموسه
في هذا كله هو عمل يعزز قدره العراق على
تلبيه تحتاجات
الاقتصاد العراقي الشقيق من الكهرباء في
السنوات القادمه كما سيعزز امن واستقرار
الشبكات الكهربائيه المترابطه واود هنا ان
نعبر عن تقديري
وتقديم العمل لتقديم العمل في مشروع
كهرباء ربط الكهربائي السعودي في العراق
المباشر الذي يشرف عليه فريق عمل مشترك من
المملكه ومن العراق
من جهتها كذا وزير الكهرباء زياد فاضل على
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لمشروع الربط
الكهربائي الجديد
وضع الحجر الاساسي لمشروع الربط الذي
يتضمن تنفيذ خط بدائلتين من محطه الزور
الثانويه مرورا مرورا بمحطه الوفره الى
محطه الفاو وبطول كلي 322 كيلومتر وان
مقدار الطاقه المتوقعه المتوقعه استيرادها
من خلال هذه الخط كمرحله الاولى سيبلغ 500
ميجا [__] لتغذيه محافظه البصره
[موسيقى]
اوردت صحيفه بوليتيكون وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلين كان يخطط للسفر في
اقرب وقت الاسبوع المقبل كان قد الغى رحله
في وقت سابق من هذا العام بسبب ما عرف
بازمه بالون التجسس الصيني ذكرت وكاله
رويتنز الانباء ان بلينكن سيتوجه الى
الصين لاجراء محادثات في الاسابيع المقبله
اعلنا الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس
الوزراء البريطاني شراكه اقتصاديه جديده
بين البلدين تهدف لخوض التحديات الجيو
السياسيه الكبيره الراهنه خصوصا في مواجهه
طموحات الصين ينص اعلان واطلسي على بنود
عدابينها تعزيز التعاون في الصناعه الدفاع
وتوريد المعادن الضروريه في الانتقال على
الصعيد الطاقه
نفل بيت الابيض تقريرا اعلاميا افاد بان
الولايات المتحده وايران تقتربان من اتفاق
مؤقت تقلص طهرا بموجابه برنامجها النووي
مقابل التخفيف العقوبات عنها وصف متحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض
التقريب المضلل في اشاره الى مقال بموقع
مدى الالكتروني نقل معلومات غير صحيحه عن
مصادر لم يحدد هويتها
الى الولايات المتحده والوضع في نيويورك
الذي يبدو انها تعافت من اثار دخان حرائق
الغابات في كندا في اخر الاجراءات
الاحترازيه كانت اداره الطيران الفيدراليه
علقت رحلات الجويه من شمال شرق ولايه
وهايو الى مطار جارديا في نيويورك مؤقتا
[موسيقى]
كما ادى الدخان الناتج عن الحرائق كان جاي
الى ضعف الرؤيه في العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن وتدهور جوده الهواء فيها فيما حذر
مسؤولون المواطنين من البقاء في الخارج
لاوقات طويله
عاده عندما نكون هنا في هذا المكان قرب
نصب واشنطن نستطيع ان نرى الكونجرس
الامريكي بوضوح لكن اليوم الموضوع مختلف
لان الرؤيه ضعيفه والسبب وصول دخان حرائق
كندا الى العاصمه واشنطن الذي اثر ايضا
على جوده الهواء ما دفع عمده العاصمه الى
دعوه المواطنين الى عدم البقاء في الخارج
لاوقات طويله الا اذا كانوا مضطرين لذلك
كما دعم مسؤولون امريكيون الى اتخاذ
الاحتياطات كارتداء الكمامات لعدم استنشاق
الهواء الملوث ويخشى الباحثون من ان تسبب
الجزئيات الدخانيه الصغيره باضرار تنفسيه
للاشخاص لانهم ورغم صغارها قادره على
الحاق ضرر بالمسالك التنفسيه من المتوقع
ان يصل دخان الحرائق الى الولايات الوسطى
الغربيه وايضا الى الولايات الجنوبيه
الشرقيه الى ولايه جورجيا تحديدا
دخان حرائق كندا يخنق جيرانها الولايات
المتحده اول المتضررين وقد لا تكون اخرهم
السلطات الكنديه اعلنت محاولتها اخماد نحو
423 حريقا نشطا
246 منها خارجه عن السيطره تسببت الحرائق
بالقضاء على حوالي ثلاثه ملايين 800 الف
هكتار فيما تحولت مقاطعه
للحرائق حيث ينشط فيها 160 حريقا الى جانب
عشرات الحرائق الاخرى في البرتا وكولومبيا
البريطانيه وانتاريو دخان حرائق الغابات
القادمه من كندا سيؤثر على اكثر من 55
مليون شخص في مناطق الشمال الشرقي ووسط
الولايات المتحده ابرزها نيويورك وبوسطن
واشنطن نيويورك المعروفه عاده بسمائها
الصافيه سجلت اسوا مؤشر لجوده الهواء
عالميا وفق موقع اي كيو ار السويسري
المختص في مراقبه حاله الهواء
مخاوفه بانتقال الحرائق الى غابات
الولايات المتحده المتاخمه على بعد اكثر
من
5800 كيلو متر من كندا حيث تقع النرويج
يتوقع ان تدفع الرياح بدخان الحرائق الى
هناك وفق مسؤولين نرويجيين حيث سجلت
جزيئات متطايره من الدخان جنوبيا النرويج
بينما تحرك الدخان فوق جرين لاند وايسلندا
منذ الاول من يونيو الحكومه الكنديه تتوقع
استمرار نشاط الحرائق بصوره اعلى من
المعتاد وصدبابيه توقيت ومكان توقف السحب
الدخانيه وعوده الهواء لطبيعته لارتباطها
باتجاه الرياح وسرعتها
في النهايه نشرت تذكيرا بابرز العناوين
يواجه سمعتها الجنائيه لاحتفاضه بوثائق
سريه ومكارتي يتواعد اداره بايدن
بالمحاسبه
البنتاجون يستعد لتقديم مساعدات عسكريه
جديده لكلاب يتحدث عن تحقيق نتائج شرق
اوكرانيا
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه تعلن ممثل الامم
المتحده الخاص فولكر شخصا غير مرغوب فيه
نهايه نشرع شكرا لكم على كرم المتابعه في
امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات